[Music]
I've never been much for smoking but
taking a bullet to the chest will make
you a lot less worried about the slow
deaths of the world long story short I
took a job I shouldn't have
they say the pretty ones will always get
you killed but he was so damn handsome I
just couldn't resist I was a frog in a
slow pot of boiling water or the first
clown to get into the clown car you
don't know to get out until it's too
late
one thing led to another and I found
myself slow dancing with a devil in the
moonlight except instead of leaving room
for Jesus
he left room for a 357 magnum I won't
bore you with the details so I'll cut
right to the quick a lot of people died
because of this man William J dammit
come on William J Barnum aka the colonel
just like the clown in my bar mitzva I
knew he was trouble from the moment I
laid eyes on him and just like bozo the
Magnificent a lot of people died when he
walked into my life I've been chasing
him down ever since we were like two
naked men running on the same treadmill
uncomfortably close but always just a
step behind but no one can run forever
especially not with 200 pounds of sweaty
detective breathing down your neck it
hasn't been easy though I can't count
how many countries I've cornered him in
couldn't tell you how many times I've
had him in my big strong
every time I think I've got him for good
he somehow manages to slip away but he's
running out of holes to hide in I mean
that literally metaphorically and
euphemistically he doesn't matter how
crafty you think you are if you've been
on the run for years on the years or
eventually you're gonna make a mistake
word of advice if you're running away
from your problems never become too
attached to anything family lovers
briefcases on top of your car
some things are best left behind
the Colonel's a slippery one shedding
names as easily as a snake sheds a few
pounds before bikini season he's gone
through suiting him after suiting him
trying to cover his tracks but he always
manages to fall back into the same
familiar roles drinking fighting
flirting dancing
[Music]
the Colonel's always what eccentrics
what is the latest persona takes the
entire cake shop user mother-loving
would stash
[Music]
[Applause]
get your ass down
don't move [ __ ] your heads
[Music]
get down on the ground get down on the
ground right now Oh why'd the music stop
you're not getting away from me this
time [ __ ] I said get your ass down on
the ground do I know you
I said get down what how do you not stop
playing games
get your ass down on the ground before I
blow you right here right now away Dave
Dave Dave Dave Greg Steve yeah Dave I
knew I recognized you how are you how's
the wife I don't have a wife stop
stalling you're under arrest for the
murder of way too many people to even
count well that's just ridiculous I
would never kill anybody oh is that
right whatever you say buddy
you ran a real good race there buddy
it's the end of the road for you the law
is gonna throw every book they have at
you and after that they're gonna throw
you in a Cell and after that they're
gonna throw away the key and after that
they're gonna throw that cell into a
lake
but not before I throw a few things at
him first we're gonna play pin the tail
on the donkey
but he's the donkey and the tail is my
feelings but I shouldn't get ahead of
myself I only get one night with him to
fill the hole in my heart he left behind
it's finally time to get some answers
did we date at some point no we didn't
date the hole is a metaphor for when you
shot me in the holy [ __ ] that was close
we could have taken them what the hell
does that have to do with how did you
how are you how many fingers am i
holding up for aardvark
pumpernickel what are you doing
Calabasas are you okay how are you in my
head why are you selling get out of my
head you're still shouting
[Applause]
enough Kings your ass is mine
for the next 24 hours oh and I'm gonna
take my sweet time with that ass to get
answers out of it
from you well well I I suppose I could
stay here a while D comfortable lovely
place you've got here
could you be more colors enough with
your [ __ ]
do you have any remorse any remorse at
all for the things you've done or are
you too much of a coward to face your
crimes well there's no need for
name-calling words can hurt you know you
should be kind in fairness yes
name-calling huh and what name would you
prefer is it William J Butterfield
well here's the name aha Wilson Jackson
Bartholomew the third well now I
actually married its best
Wingull heimer wait just wiggle himer
all right they may have been having a
little bit of fun with our name after
name after name after name just so you
could distance yourself from the real
name you should be called
even hey it's been years how are you how
are you doing how's my family I'm doing
just peachy buddy because I've been
waiting a long long time for this day to
come so we could sit down have a chat
catch up good and proper Wow there we
all are how the hell did you do that
yeah you better get your ass back in
that chair also how did you get your ass
out of that chair you're gonna tell me
you're gonna tell me how you got your
ass out of that chair so I can figure
out a way to get it back in that chair
oh there Selene my heart still beats for
her to this day but if she saw me she
probably carved mine out how did you
find I've always had them I've been
collecting them every single scrap of
evidence this whole time so that one day
I can bring you down it's not sweet
sickening sickening really sweet that's
not what I meant
look I am terribly terribly sorry that I
didn't remember you memories start to
get jumbled after a while sometimes I
forget things Oh trust me you'll have
plenty of time to think about all the
horrible things you've done once they
throw you in a cage then throw away the
key and then throw that how the hell do
you keep doing that please get jumbled
so easily the wind the way the why the
how of it all who can keep track of it
seriously need to get back in the chair
I've got more rope maybe that'll work
yeah worth a shot Oh the train oh I
remember the train how long were we
stuck in the snow for
oh you don't remember that's ok probably
hasn't happened yet but some of your
finest work I have to say a little
spoiler alert for later to make it
easier on you we all did it
understand no no the grown-ups are
talking
save that for later the hell's going on
huh I don't really know honestly i i i
don't understand anything anymore but i
do remember you and I remembered that
there's something I've been meaning to
give you after all these years get
awesome if there's one thing I've
learned after all these years it's that
nothing heals like a good apology
exactly none of this makes any sense
that's the beauty of it beauty
what about any of this is beautiful to
you what kind of sick twisted son of a
[ __ ] thinks any of this is beautiful
now what did we say about name calls you
killed people so many people you killed
my friends
you killed my partner you shot me now it
seems to me like you're trying to paint
me as the bad guy you are the bad guy
whoa hey whoa time out
kind of kind of hey I get it
you've been hunting me for years and
years and years you've been chasing me
all around the world from a bedrooms two
bathrooms two ballrooms you've been
chasing me and you've been doing a real
bang-up job of it but and and forgive me
if this sounds insulting in any way what
would you say are our closest encounter
was before this very moment right here
when was her closest encounter yeah
before this very moment yes
that's easy it was when we when we you
yeah you know it was when you um that's
when you were I was hunting you down I
was stalking you but you fled the
country to uh all right all right yeah
oh yeah you were you were off the radar
for three years but I got a hot tip you
checked up in uh in our mouths you
shacked up with you know three years
what year was that exactly what what
year it was in it was
I can't remember
I've obsessed over this case for years
every moment of every day
spend trying to hunt you down
so why can't I remember
am I crazy no no no no my friend you are
not crazy don't let anyone ever tell you
that you are crazy
you used to focused on the minutiae of
it the details but who killed who who
slept with who it you're not focusing on
the big picture it's impossible to know
things that haven't happened yet yes
exactly
just like it's impossible to survive a
bullet this was all a nightmare that I
couldn't wake up from my heart was
pounding Morse code to my ears but I
never learned the language my mind was
like a hamster ball rolling down the
freeway no matter how fast I went I
couldn't keep up with the flow it was my
first year of Clown College all over
again and no no no drifting off just
listen it was a bit of a shock for me
too life needed a bit of madness but why
should death be a need but I think the
stress is getting to a little bit you
need to unwind you're you're a freshly
born farm trying to find your legs in
the world it doesn't make sense
so just for tonight let's forget about
all that
we were chasing and the killing and the
shooty shooty bang bang god you're a
murderer
just for tonight
why don't we
[Music]